maybe there are principles
very economical very powerful principles
which we haven't yet figured out which
will resolve the paradoxes we have
such as the dark matter the dark energy
the Big Bang itself uh what goes on in
black holes you know that they're very
very basic paradoxes and maybe we just
need to think a little harder
um so after I've started following this
line of research about five years ago
it's very difficult because you've
essentially tied your hands together I'm
not allowed to introduce a new particle
okay and but we've made amazing progress
at least I find it amazing we've
realized what the dark matter is it's
probably a right-handed neutrino which
is already there in the standard model
it's extremely economical explanation
we've found
this is something I'm most excited about
recently a new explanation for why the
universe is so simple on large scales
you know the the geometry of the
universe what is the universe like on
large scale well in first approximation
it's flat space it's the thing you learn
about in geometry in Primary School
you know there's X Y and Z there's no
curve at curvature at all why is it the
simplest possible geometry it's a huge
puzzle which motivated the theory of
inflation so now we have a new
explanation
and the explanation is extremely
economical
it it doesn't make it easy to understand
but it basically developed Stephen
Hawking's ideas about black holes
and we
we literally do a calculation of the
thermodynamics of the universe
which
I'll I'll say
very briefly
shows that you know just like the gas in
a room
um
will distribute itself evenly in space
because that is the most probable
configuration of the atoms if you Chuck
them in with some energy allow them to
randomize they will spread themselves
out uniformly in a smooth distribution
you don't have to introduce somebody to
smooth that or do something active
another field or particle it just does
it itself that's thermodynamics and so
we figured out the thermodynamics of the
cosmos
using Hawking's insights and with no
finagling
um with new particles or whatever with
some very simple mathematical
assumptions we find the most probable
universe is flat uh exactly the geometry
we see and it's the simplest geometry
and so
that's an entirely new explanation it
doesn't require any new ingredients it
will take people a long time to accept
this well aware of that because people
have built their careers for 40 years on
differing different assumptions but I'm
personally very excited about it I think
what we're seeing is a way through
to explain all the puzzles all the major
puzzles in theoretical physics
with absolutely minimal additions to
what we already know
well there was a man who was an alumna
alumnus of uh irfine University who had
uh had a fair a bit of experience with
simplification with unification and uh
with really constructing a strict
mathematical model of the universe and
uh it worked pretty well uh except for
the fact that it was also based on very
simple principles involving gears and
vortices and whirlpools and of course
we're speaking about the late great uh
James Clerk Maxwell who's Italian and
all of a sudden and maybe you know in
the spirit of uh of a Higgs or a Yang
Mills or uh in the same in the same way
what do you make of his ultimate what he
did Neil is so interesting because he
was absolutely correct for all the wrong
reasons and we see that again and again
in science you see that with Galileo he
was right about Universal gravity or
Newton was right about universal
gravitation completely wrong about how
it propagated Galileo was completely
right about the the orbit of the Earth
around the Sun thought it was
responsible for the tides that prove it
had nothing to do with the times
um but tell me Neil is it possible
sometimes that brilliant theorists
can have the right idea for the wrong
reason and in that way give us a glimpse
of Truth and maybe could that be
happening with inflation in the
Multiverse just to be a little bit of a
steel man and yeah yeah no it's a good
question and it's a big puzzle why
inflation and the Multiverse have become
so popular
because objectively this is a theory
with uh an infinite variety of models of
lots of parameters lots of Freedom
extremely hard to prove wrong
um so on the face of it
uh it's a theory which isn't
particularly scientific
traditionally it would be regarded as
unfalsifiable and therefore not part of
science
but um what happened is the field of
theoretical physics has kind of been
pushed into a corner
where many of The Luminaries I mean very
uh great theorists like Stephen Weinberg
um who you know was more or less a
founder of our modern picture of of uh
physics and the standard model
um came around to this point of view of
the Multiverse and inflation
and I've I always found it sort of
surprising uh that they did but they did
for for for
you know what you could say were good
reasons I mean there's a certain logic
behind the steps people followed
but it's just a case of you know when
you when when you make a few one false
turn
and there's no uh kind of experimental
check
or insufficient experimental checks you
can very easily go wrong and so I think
I think that's what's happened I think
in fact around the time I entered
theoretical physics you know
um in the 1980s
um the uh that's when the field went
wrong okay I'm not saying it was my
fault
Steven had something to do with it I
think Stephen Hawking had a little bit
to do with it he actually in in A Brief
History of Time which I went back and
read after his death yeah it's a big
deal about not only is uh is is there no
boundary is there no beginning but but
that you know the CMB basically proves
that there is an inflation there is a
Multiverse and uh and he really went
quite quite uh and he's so influential
uh although my first guess my first ever
guest on the podcast uh was Freeman
Dyson uh who I loved and uh was
incredibly influential I'm sure you knew
him when you were a professor at
Princeton as well yeah many interactions
with he he said the safest thing in life
to do Neil is to make a bet with Stephen
Hawking because either he was wrong uh
AB initio or he would eventually switch
positions so you'd win no matter what
[Music]